we are going to build the wall it will
be a real war a real war
are you ready
this is the Rio Grande that is Mexico
that is the United States Texas and that
is Mother Nature's wall it's pretty
great the Rio Grande starts at Colorado
flows through New Mexico and becomes the
us-mexico border when it enters Texas a
border wall already exists along the
river in urban areas as for the rest it
is some of the most inhospitable terrain
in the southwest
on both sides of the border there are
national parks state parks wildlife
areas and historic ranches that go back
for centuries
this region is like the Greater
Yellowstone Ecosystem of the Chihuahua
desert and the last true wilderness left
in the state of Texas desert bighorn
sheep went extinct in this region but
they've been reintroduced and once again
battle for breeding rights along both
sides of the Rio Grande
the physical border wall would block
them from the Rio Grande the only
reliable water source along with
everything else that depends on the
river for water for survival
black bears were also killed out west
texas then about 25 years ago a female
came out of the Malins in mexico cross
the Rio Grande and had Cubs a Big Bend
National Park
the Bears are back now about 40 of them
the border wall would isolate them
genetically and prohibit future
dispersals for them and other important
species
I wish that everybody who wanted to
build an actual physical wall could come
and see this place first because I think
if they came saw it and realized what
the wall was going through and what it
would do it would have a profound impact
on their way to think it
the Chihuahuan Desert has landscapes and
an array of life that rivals Yellowstone
whose Sydney in the Serengeti
but it's rewilding efforts the research
and the conservation work here has just
begun in the center it's the Rio Grande
River
a border for us
but the heartbeat for this ecosystem a
flowing changing desert oasis
the lifeline during drought
we're gonna build the wall folks we're
gonna build that wall will go up so fast
your head will spin and you'll say you
know he meant it
you